hey guys it's May you can check me out
on the bootleg Kev
podcast blle cev show man uh we got a
special guest in here from Brooklyn Maya
the dawn big Don welcome thank you
you're in town uh here in La you are on
tour with Flo Millie this is your first
tour yes how many dates in are you um
two dates
in and I'm having a good time so you
like it so far I do it's hard work it is
I got to wake up early go to bed late do
a lot of time do rehearsal right oh yes
I'm very anal about that we rehearse
every day I was going to say do you have
like uh like what's your live show like
do you have dancers do you have yes I
have dancers DJ we go the whole nine wow
it's very extravagant so the dancer
thing is is it like do you guys go
through like you f you find out you're
going on tour then you get your dancers
together and you guys get the
choreography popping or like how's that
work I was wondering yeah that's pretty
much how it goes it's like or just like
oh we have the is coming up so we're
going to prepare and how we prepare you
got the same crew of dancers always yeah
nice I work with the same danc um you
just did the BET ciphers too which was
dope yes yes that was really cool it's
always like a I feel like if you're like
a dope rapper like that's one of the
things that like really stamps you every
year for sure you know what I mean for
sure I feel like that [__] is cooler
than the the XXL cover at this point no
disrespect you know oh why you feel like
that I just feel like if you're like a
spitter it's like you know I feel like
the ciphers is what really kind kind
like they really put like the real like
for sure a lot of people can't do a scii
that's okay though right and like on
like sometimes on the XXL like you know
a lot of people can't do the cipher
there but they still do it but like
they're not great at rapping sometimes I
feel like the Bett they curate it really
well is what I'm
saying STS you know and you're from
Brooklyn you better be able to rap right
hey could you imagine if you were from
Brooklyn and you couldn't rap be crazy I
don't know it's like it's in me not on
me that is 100% how long have you been
spitting
um I've been rapping seriously for like
a year and a half that's it yeah you
started rapping during Co no after Co so
maybe like a year seriously what yeah
but I've always like written songs you
like really good thank
you thank you how's that work cuz PE
there's listen I know 45-year-old grown
men grown men mhm and they're still
trying I write I wrote every day right
every single day and I I was a student I
listened to music listened to who wrote
what found out the production like
really just identified what makes a good
rapper and why who was that that you
were like you know listening to who were
you studying
everybody everybody I listen to my
favorites like I first I identify what I
wanted to sound like what do I why do I
want to rap like what is what's going to
be your message what's going to be your
your impact on hip-hop on female rap on
just being you know creative as an
individual um I identified that and then
it was like easy like I know I love Rick
Ross I want to be like a girl Rick Ross
how I do that I'm going to listen to
every single Rick Ross album EP mixtape
every feature everything you know and
just listen to what forwards and
backwards okay what women do I love who
you know what makes them phenomenal
women in music not even just rap you
know right listen to uh Missy Elliot
albums fors and backwards like you know
just really identifying what it is that
makes good music good music and then
applying it to myself so would you say
like Rick Ross and Missy were like the
two kind of Rick Ross and JZ yeah for
sure in terms of like um substance yeah
you know what I'm saying like Rick Ross
makes me feel good um Jay-Z makes me
feel good it's like they're like perfect
rappers in my
book whole heartedly like Circle it's
like five things people need it's like
uh there's like Nas Jay-Z Rick Ross
Benny The Butcher Conway like the one
rap city these in that's people Eve to
me like it's just certain people that
like has everything rapy don't get
enough flowers cuz she one of the she's
she alien she's crazy word an alien
she's an alien like crazy what's your
favorite Rick Ross album oh I can't
answer that question I can't answer that
question I just I can't I feel like Rick
Ross albums are perfect every single one
a couple of them are every single one
and I I see I'm not even G to argue with
you about it that's why no no no Teflon
Dawn is a classic Teflon da is a class
Deeper Than Rap it's my favorite though
but Teflon Dawn and Deeper Than Rap are
my two it's one of them two uh then he
has some like Mastermind was cool like
he's got you know God forbid God
forgives I don't like uh r makes great
albums selfmade uh MMG shits were fire
no Ross is great that but my [__] is
Rich Forever his mixtape yeah Rich
Forever was crazy Rich Forever is like
Albert Anastasia shout out to Ros man
one of the greatest of all time I got
him in my personal top 10 Rick Ross
don't get enough credit neither I say
that all the time he don't get enough
credit that's like he's got one of the
smoothest flows ever he's got the best
ear for production ever for sure and
he's [__] Rick Ross Rick Ross is like
he's just so expensive like I always say
Rick R could make you feel like your 19
uh 92 beater is a rollsroyce new year
like you know what I'm saying like he
just makes you feel so expensive he make
you want to get up and stop being broke
it's that it's that beat selection his
beat sound it's something about his
voice so powerful yeah cinematic it's so
like he just he Demands a room he
demands attention and that's like what I
want have you had any any um of your
Idols or any of the people that you
studied like reach out to you or yes Kim
um cardi they're all they're both so
supportive and so so kind and sweet to
me like and their fans are kind of
together yes I've realized that cuz I
said something before about little Kim
that uh people didn't like I didn't even
say anything too crazy but nonetheless I
got the brunt of the fans that were like
they were like queen bees is that what
they call them the be the m and then the
cardi B fans are and then I'm cool with
like offsetting cardi so like then like
6 months later I was like I said
something about the song jealousy like I
don't know 6 months before I came out
cuz I heard it and then all those same
people who were like threatening to
murder me were like bootle K says
there's a new cardian on off I was like
good Lord yo do you have a name for your
fans yes my fans is the mafia oh the D
you know what I'm saying the Mafia the
Mafia the mob you know are they toxic I
don't think so I I like to tell my fans
like be kind exactly be respectful not
even be kind cuz you don't got to be
kind to people people won [__] with me
all right that's cool but you be
respectful we here for me we don't pay
attention to anybody else you know what
I'm saying like support who support me
support everybody until they're not
supportive and then it's [__] some of
these toxic fans I just wonder like who
are these people in real life does that
does that make sense what I'm saying I'm
not talking about your fans cuz you'll
see some of these fans whether it's the
little Kim fans or the barbs or just
some of these human beings they say
things on the internet that are so crazy
I just want to know what they do from
like 8:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. on a Monday
right like what do y'all do in real life
nothing nothing it's just crazy like
toxic did you see that show swarm on
Amazon I did see it I did that show is
crazy crazy ass show what do you watch
on TV what are your go-tos I like like
murder mystery of course you
do is it sexist to say that that like
why is that a woman thing like every
woman loves that kind of [__] it might
be like sexist it's a little sexist but
it's also men are [__] that's why
there it is but isn't that not true look
my wife all her friends everybody I know
they all my my mom oh my god when my mom
and my wife get together they're just
[__] binge watching serial killer
[__] yes I love it shitty reenactments
with shitty actors oh wow they're
interviewing the the detectives the it's
just yeah I like stuff like that or I
like um I like this show called suits
right now I don't suits that's got the
girl who the the the uh what's Megan Mar
in it right yeah yeah she's phenomenal
in cuz that's like an older show that
kind of just repoed right on Netflix it
stopped in like 2017 I want to say good
though yeah I really like show like like
that mhm I like I like stuff like that
suits Grace's Anatomy um what's the
other one um with Matthew greay gobler
that I can't think of [__] sick name
right
there I can't think of the show name but
people going did you watch Scandal I
like so like Scandal Scandal was fire
yeah shout out to her she's she's lovely
for sure man what was her name on the
show Olivia Olivia Pope yes the fixer
yeah I you know I don't ever want to be
like successful enough to where I would
need to hire someone like
her that's real as [__] cuz Olia Pope
was just getting her hands dirty bro
like I'm like I don't want to be that
important to ever have to call like
Olivia you know what I'm saying like
real [__] that's
some yeah that's just another level of
uh yeah yeah shout out to Olivia poo
well is is it about being successful is
it because you [__] up I don't know
doing dumb [__] I don't know bro that's
why you call Olivia cuz you doing stupid
[__] that is true and then she was I
kind of had like I was like she's in the
white guys you know mhm that's somebody
who's a Caucasian who's into melanated
women I was
like I was like hell yeah hey the
president's taking that [__] down bro
let's go oh my God is that is that is
that like is that like a niche thing is
that like no I mean I just I so I'm
married to a Mexican woman and my kids
are half Mexican I just don't I'm not
into any I'm not into white women at all
they're kind of like I just don't they
just remind me of like my family you
know like I don't want to [__] somebody
who looks like my cousin you know like
right right so I understand so also like
white women are like it's like when you
go to the candy aisle and like there's
all the packs of M&M's she's about to
say some real crazy misogynistic sex sh
no no no no no so like a white woman is
like you get the brown bag of M&M's and
like nobody wants the brown bag of M&M's
you want the yellow bag when they got
the peanut butter ones you want like no
one's doing plain M&M's unless it's all
they got you know what I'm saying like
so I kind of damn and I'm I'm just damn
he just white woman on like a t-shirt
but hey but listen I'm also a plain
Eminem yeah I'm a white man so I also
I'm in I'm I'm like an Eminem mini in
the little tube you
know I just I prefer mine you know I
like I like some peanuts in MY M&M's you
know or some yeah little flavor what
just a little flavor just a little
little flavor like and like white women
can't cook like my mom can't cook you
know like she could cook enough so what
does that look like when growing up with
like a mom that can't cook what do you
well listen listen I my mom can cook
enough but she's listen Thanksgiving at
my house versus Thanksgiving at my
wife's family's house there's just a lot
more seasoning
obviously yeah shout out to my mom and
my aunt and my sister they can't cook
for [__] damn I mean they can cook like
they're here's food you know but it's
like is it like great like right like my
dad can cook better than my mom my dad
Cooks way better than my mom is your dad
white yeah m but he's like hillbilly
white so I feel like it's a little
different they got a little more like I
don't know like he'll he'll put like
he'll like uh make everything in bacon
grease yeah or he'll have a roast and he
like marinates the roast in Coca-Cola
for like 12 hours and that [__] is gas
[__] that it's also it's it's fire hell
no it's really good I don't want nothing
marinated in no Coca-Cola you don't
drink soda I don't drink Coca-Cola what
do you
drink if you had to drink of soda
I like Dr Peppa yo Coke is the wave hell
no if you're going to pick a
soda I like Sala you like a Seltzer like
a white claw or like a more like regular
like like seltzer water yeah oh yeah
that's gross what a black cherry salsa
fire I'm good I like it cuz sometimes we
just need the bubbles just a little
bubble yeah it's like a fake soda
exactly so you'll do like a what's the
thing called lro lro I'll do a lacroy
yeah that's fine I mean it's much
healthier than like the high fructose
cord syrup that's in all the Coca-Cola
that I drink Mex Mexican Coke's the wave
in the bottle right straight cane sugar
it's real
[__] it is I don't know what part of
Brooklyn are you from East New York ah
East New York M do you feel like um cuz
Brooklyn has changed cuz I've been going
to Brooklyn for probably like a little
over 10 years every time I go back it
just is like just just so different like
it looks different like I just was in
Dum is like Soho now I was like in dumbo
at some party like three or four months
ago and weren't you there with us with
uh with static selector was djn did you
come no you weren't there we're Puerto
Rico Rob who you've probably met yes I
know Puerto Rico Rob yeah shout out to
Puerto Rico Rob shout out to Rob let him
take you out one night hell no you won't
get home till like 6 in the morning he a
wild boy but nonetheless yeah it's just
Brooklyn is changing so much it's it's
its own thing now it's obviously there's
a lot of gentrification happening um for
you like what is it like being from
there do you embrace the change the
growth or do you kind of like how do you
feel about it I can't do [__] about it
right so it's
like hey this what I'm going to do cry
about it right you know what I'm saying
I don't know I
think it's [__] up like gentrification
is bad like all together yeah just like
the lack of ability to afford to live
where you grew up is crazy it's like
kind of [__] up it is [__] up not
even kind of but I can't do nothing
about it right now so I think that's
like my only opinion or feeling on it is
that it's just messed up it feels like
people like a lot of like my homies they
like they have to like move to like
[__] Jersey or Connecticut or yeah or
the Bronx yeah that's where everybody
going now everyone's moving to the Bronx
yeah cuz that's the only place you can
afford in New York it's crazy out there
nobody like no one's relocating to like
Brownsville because why Brownsville Curr
crazy place right it's like they put a
Starbucks in there I just know
Brownsville is where mop is from do you
know who that is the mash out posi okay
Annie up Annie up yeah that fool yeah
yeah yeah but yeah like brownsv is like
is is it it's not gentrified yet right
it yeah it's so funny cuz like night
shub will do [__] like put new flowers
on like outside and then like up the
rent and still like [__] up in there
that's crazy like we have flowers yeah
exactly on some wild [__] you could get
a coffee and here some flowers exactly
we need an extra $1,200 a month real
[__] damn yo what up guys we got to stop
the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie it's winning season
right now NFL we're in the thick of it
I've been doing really good on my NFL
bets by the way plus NBA officially back
we got playoff baseball it's going crazy
especially if you like to throw down
some of that money and do a little
gambling you got to head over to my
bookie uh this what's DPE about mybookie
it doesn't matter if your team sucks my
team the Cardinals they're trash don't
matter I'm still winning on Sundays baby
all right at my bookie all right you can
use my bookie for your daily odd boost
same game parlays and take advantage of
the crazy huge prize pool contest plus
right now my bookie has a no strings
attached that's the important thing no
strings attached cash bonus that let you
deposit and withdraw quick that's free
cash no strings attached deposit take it
out and then go about your day or get on
some of this NFL and NBA action baby all
right just use the promo code bootleg
when you sign up go to mybookie.ag use
the promo code bootleg on your first
deposit and you'll receive up to $200 in
cash what are we talking about no
strings attached what my bookie use the
promo code bootleg all right maybe you
want to gamble on some NFL maybe you
want to get in on some of this early NBA
action maybe you want to get in on some
of this playoff baseball it's really on
you use the promo code bootleg and
receive up to $200 in cash that's right
try my bookie right now use that promo
code bootleg and you can grab um how
about this man there's some crazy odds
going on and I like this one because
what you can do is you can throw down on
a potential Super Bowl front runner and
uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus
38,000 if you put
$100 you win
$388,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie
plus we got to give a big shout out to
our family at King pom man we love King
pom over here on the bootle C podcast
this is what's great about King pom
first of all it's all about that organic
no tobacco leaf this thing right here is
a boy look at that sure H H that's just
a leaf right there King palom they got
everything you need man they got these
cones with the squeezing pop tpin in
them the flavors this right here is the
uh the dragon fruit we got the grape HD
the watermelon wave so many flavors
what's dope about King palom if you're
in whatever City you're in you can find
King pom at your local smoke shop your
local 7-Eleven all right I'm telling you
King pom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke what you're
smoking all right you stuff one of these
boys up with some flour uh and and you
just you're Off to the Races I'm telling
you hit the tip you get hit with that
flavor and it's man it's nothing like it
the squeezing pop on King pal is insane
all right and they got all size cones
all right so go to King pom man organic
tobacco free leaves of all sizes like
this is a this is a this is look look
we're talking about all sizes here what
are we talking about what are we talking
about here boys all right go to King
pom.com right now you can order whatever
you want man they got accessories they
got trays they got Grinders they got
ashtrays they got damn all kind of
flavors of their leaves everything 50%
off when you use the promo code bootleg
that's 50% off order whatever you want
at King pom.com let's get back to the
interview um what's it like uh for you
cuz obviously you know to me New York is
kind of there's so much going on at once
right now obviously the drill shit's
super hot um shout out to Connie Diamond
she was up here yourself you're popping
you're doing your thing there so many
female MC's doing their thing Jen Carter
from 41's really dope um for you like
it's got to be exciting to kind of be a
part of this like new Resurgence this
new energy coming out of New York for
sure I'm like I'm just happy to be a
part of the team part of the ride you
know what I'm saying it's like everybody
doing their thing I hope you know we
could continue to be impactful grow
together everybody's so super talented I
respect respect all of them it's just
like it's just so cool cuz you know you
go from watching everything happening to
like blinking and now everybody my
especially like for young um people like
Jen Carter whole 41 I think what they
doing is so so cool I love [__] like
that like I love that you know they just
kids and they're positive they ain't
doing no crazy stupid [__] they so those
are so sweet kids they come on my show
twice in the last few months they're
they are so sweet I love everything
that's happening for them they like I
had them try coffee on my show for the
first time in their life I want to see
that they told me during the interview
they're like yeah we don't we ain't
never had no coffee I'm
like you've never had coffee they like
16 like nah I'm like you never had black
coffee so I went to my boy went to the
store and he got he went to 7-Eleven and
we had them everyone tried black coffee
from 7-Eleven and they all spit it out
mhm I'm bet yeah no I mean listen black
coffee is an acquired taste I like black
coffee me too I like black cfee it's
right here it's no sugar you know it's
good it go straight to your like need
like a yeah it's also laxative hell yeah
you drink that black coffee you got to
hit the [__] real
quick for you you should not be drinking
black coffee before you go on stage
right have you ever had to use a
restroom during a show actually no but
you know what's so funny every time I be
so nervous before I go on stage I be
like oh I got to pee yeah and everybody
gets annoyed but I be like I got to pee
I'll hold it it's okay and then every
time every time damn never fails I don't
know why something wrong with me when
people get nervous they piss yeah my dog
does it both of my dogs my dog gets
excited he'll pee a little bit when you
come home after not seeing your dog for
a while does he get excited and piss
everywhere yeah or his not even pee but
his penis will come out yeah I be like
put it away I'm your mother both of my
dogs dicks come out when you see him
yeah he's kind of weird it is disgusting
I'll be like can you relax like is your
dog neutered nope is it a Frenchie no
he's actually a pitbull you see him oh
nice yeah show me I'm show you I love
dogs I have a pitbull his name is Thor
who's babysitting Thor while you're my
uh sister okay my sister she is the best
Titi ever this is
Thor oh Thor is beautiful isn't he
that's a cute dog that's Thor and then
I'll show you storm I haven't gotten
stor me at she's still just a little
baby she's like 4 weeks old and it was
important to me that she stayed with her
mom the full eight weeks check you out
for people who don't know okay if a
breeder tries to sell you a dog before
it's 8 weeks old they're shitty breeders
yes they are because they're supposed to
be shoted up and with their mom exactly
yeah and this is Storm I'mma show you
her hold on she's just the cutest little
thing ever she is um um what do you call
it a um like a pull a beautiful dog
she's a beautiful dog and she's just so
freaking cute so storm and Thor are
going to be kicking it tough she's a
pocket bully is what she is a pocket
what a pocket bully oh yeah so she's
like a little mini bulldog question when
you do the BET Cipher mhm who was your
Cipher with um so DJ head was the DJ mhm
and then I did it with the Mexican OT
and Lenell Grant yo that Mexican OT is
hard yeah I couldn't understand anything
he was saying did you guys did you guys
talk yeah did he say what's up
baby yes he's so like Southern I love it
on Sunday or no Friday we're flying to
Houston MH and um I'm scared cuz I'm an
animal lover but in
Texas they're they have these pigs that
are like invasive uh breed of pigs that
like ruin all the crops and like kill uh
like pets and [__] so I'm going to fly
to Texas on
Friday and go hog hunting with that
Mexican
o
yeah I kind of feel the same way but you
know I'm GNA that does not sound fun I
know but someone's gonna kill the
Hogs if hey if it's not at least I get
the content you know that's true yeah I
do feel bad though I told I told OT I
said hey bro like do they like pick him
up and like cook them or anything like
you know so at least feel better like
are we just killing these [__] Hogs
to kill them he's like nah bro we kill
them and leave them there I'm like oh
that sounds terrible can we cook and
make some tereso burritos or something
oh my God that is equally disgusting I
don't eat pork you don't like to swine I
don't eat pork no pork on my Fork the
swine is divine hell no [__] that you
never ate the swine I don't eat pork you
like turkey
bacon oh oh it's not a thing turkey
bacon is [__] terrible that's not
true have you ever had real bacon I
don't like you've never had I don't do
pork I had bacon actually I got a a a
burger this was months ago probably like
a year ago now and I don't eat bacon I
don't eat pork period so I bit into my
burger and I was like this burger is
salty like a [__] like why do it
taste like this bacon bacon inside oh my
God I could have cried so you've never
just had a piece of bacon by itself in
your life no I this is this is this is
well you know what you're missing out I
just want to let you know that bacon
that bacon be smacking [__] that the
swine is divine [__] that run hey so
right more Pig for
me go ahead cook that pig oh I love what
is like one food like uh me and my
co-host on my radio show James we were
just talking about this cuz this past
weekend I had um I was in
Florida and uh you know like I'll be out
here I'll be thinking I'm doing good
eating right and [__] and then I'll go
to like hit the road and I'll Just Fall
the [__] off cuz I had pizza is the one
thing I could never get rid of like any
what is your favorite like if you if you
there was a food you just had to put it
top tier you know what I'm saying mac
and cheese oh yeah I love mac and cheese
yo mac and cheese if you you go to
certain restaurants they got lobster mac
and cheese it's like I don't like none
of that I you don't like the lobster mac
and cheese straight regular homemade
baked mac and cheese do you make a good
mac and cheese I make a great Mac do I
make a good mac and cheese there's a
great science to that back to my my my
white family my mom and my sister like
they think they make great mac and
cheese right they think they do but they
don't because have you ever said this to
your mom and sister kind of M yeah it's
giving [__]
kind of you should call your mom and
just be like Mom Mom your mac and cheese
is ass yeah yeah exactly yeah cuz then
like you know give us a we straight my
wife's mac and cheese is fire she she's
Mexican but she cooks mac and cheese uh
like soul food style that was racist I
was going to say you saying you want to
say something racist right that was RAC
yeah my wife's Mexican but she she cooks
Mac and chees like a black
lady she does she does I need like a
button right now so I could be like
every time Kev says that I'm
racist no can't say that so um yo we got
to stop the interview again and tell you
about our folks at odd Soxs baby that's
right shout out to odd Soxs man the most
comfortable socks in the world they've
been riding with us since day one um and
let me tell you something man Christmas
time is is really sneaking up um
oddsocks official.com use the promo code
bootleg save 20% off at checkout they
got the crazy licenses check out these
Naruto socks [__] fire little
SpongeBob socks you know what I'm saying
how about this how about the how high
movie socks they got the WWE they got
the [__] Cheeto socks you know
what I'm saying shout out to the
[__] Cheeto socks they just
dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Ahad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Sox Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet feet is
really what they are get them black
white red [__] tie-dye whatever
you're into and they got the underwear
baby L Reese's boys let's go oddsocks
official.com use the promo code bootleg
they got South Park underwear too all
the licenses WWE Scarface Breaking Bad
South Park Power Rangers Monopoly
Coca-Cola they got it all use that promo
code bootleg and save 20% off at
checkout also want to give a shout out
to our sponsor uh much love to our good
Folks at bluechew that's right we talk
about it all the time on the podcast
when you go to blu.com right now you can
get your first month for free a lot of
people ask well what is blue and does it
work well bluechew it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra and Calis
the only difference is you don't have to
go to the doctor it's all online you go
to blu.com you get your [__] handled
over there and then they get you handled
by sending you a month for free when you
use the promo code bootleg blu.com promo
code bootleg try out out bluechew it'll
have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh blueo will have you right
like I said same active ingredient as
viagran Calis minus the awkward doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discreet package pag in blue chewable
form it's in a little it's a little
chewable man you take that thing down
and then you go to Pound Town take your
shorty to Pound Town godamn it blue.com
use that promo code bootleg try it for
free for a month let's get back to the
interview what are you working on right
now obviously tour is very popping um
what what I know you got the hot
commodity ship going down yes hot
commodity mixtape just dropped go tune
in got some good people on there but I'm
you know hopefully I'm working on like
maybe possibly a deluxe you know who's
on the original right now I have Talan
shy bin laddin and Ma shout out to Tai
shout out to Tai did you get to like
hang with him nah no I met him real
quick I just I seen them like on chance
at of Apple music event and I was like
yo let's see if I can get him to answer
the phone right now on FaceTime okay
let's see he might be with Kanye West
doing a seance for the new album he
probably won't even know who I
am imag he goes he's like who is this I
have to explain to him he's on my song
like hey you know you're on her album
well I think when you're like the hook
God like Tai's one of those guys who's
like the go-to Hook
guy who else is one of like blast is
getting there who else a a boogie a hook
guy a boogie is definitely a hook guy I
feel like a Boogie's he's not going to
answer it's a busy man he's I mean he is
dropping a joint album with Kanye proba
let me see if I can get married to
answer the phone no
Mary J blig yeah Jesus do you know Mary
J blig yes Mary is my bestie really mhm
that's pretty I felt like cuz when you
said that like oh let me see if I could
get TI and I felt like you was trying to
like upstage me a little bit nah get
married on the
phone I want to just tell her she's
amazing nah I ain't going to call Mary
the thing about Mary J blig is like you
know I kind of really I would and saw
her in Brooklyn
in what when was I in New York last year
or she she had the tour in New York I
was about to say she was on tour that
[__] was amazing she's amazing and she
brought out everybody in she is amazing
everybody shows up for Mar she had J on
there uh Fab uh [__] Diddy came out
that [__] was crazy she be having
everybody outside she didn't do a verses
either which I think would have been
like do versus with me I would like to
have just seen her put someone to shame
you know what I'm saying I was about
said who the [__] going to do that with
Mar there was like I feel like all the
cuz you know who else I wanted to see do
a versus cuz I just wanted to see him
destroy whoever they put him against
would have been Buster
Rhymes Buster would have [__] caught
a bust ain't doing versus no cuz
everybody's
scared he did not do one because
everybody was scared to get that work
work Buster Rhymes
live yeah I seen him um live I went to
go see 50 Cent oh me too phenomenal 50
people aren't famous no more did you go
to New York I no I went to like Jersey
yeah I went to Jersey how was it to see
did he bring anybody out nobody is
famous no more like it was like so like
mindblowing like 20 20 25 years later
you got people grown ass men coming to
from far away wearing [__] wife
beaters and bulletproof vests like white
men yeah dressed like 50 Cent that [__]
was it was inherently they weren't in
black face were they God I got ass
imagine that' be terrible that would be
terrible it was like it was so amazing
like it was just the coolest [__] ever
like I always say like the go mhm like
and you know Buster was on with him so
like just watching them perform like
even at the BET Awards watching LL Cool
J BT Awards this sh everybody like no
back track they running up and down 40
years old and not and they're not yeah
yeah that's the one thing these young
kids are lot like this whole generation
raps over their [__] vocals and like
you see 50 that tour was I told
everybody Cyrus you came to that tour
right no TK came that [__] was crazy it
was like beautiful the production the
and when all the tours were getting
cancelled 50 was selling out everywhere
I said man look bro they phenomenal like
it was just so amazing I was like that's
so crazy I hope in 25 years yeah I
tweeted that that was probably I think
it was my I I tweeted it out but it's
probably my favorite concert I've been
to In Like A decade damn that was just
crazy wow I was just like 50 doing all
the hits like damn like where this [__]
where's this [__] at anymore you know
what I'm saying that [__] was crazy bust
was really cool too oh yeah like when he
did the thing where uh split star was
like turning him up and he started
rapping low and he start yes and he he
was doing the DJ thing that [__] was
crazy so if you just started rapping
what was the
what like changed your life as a rapper
what was was it my first song so just
you that song went crazy and then and
then all of a sudden you're just in it
your first song ever recorded Y no not
ever recorded ever ever released yeah
like my first this is my song boom and
was there something that like you guys
did was it Tik Tock was it what was the
Catalyst of that I just I posted it
everywhere I posted on Tik Tok Instagram
and Twitter all did a million views
wow just a snip it yo man
congratulations thank you so much that's
a big deal yes it is cuz a lot of people
man they you know they got to they
everyone's path is different in hip-hop
so it's dope to see and you're really
you're a high level rapper he's the one
who sent me your [__] and was like yo we
got to get her on she's hard I love that
shout out to you Buie thank you um
what's what you
see the in my one it was the one I
showed you yeah you like that period so
the mixtape is out people can support it
Deluxe on the way hopefully hopefully
I'm I'm still stuck on if I want to do a
deluxe I feel like the deluxe thing was
like happening for a while but I've
noticed like it's the artists stopped
doing it you know what I would do a
deluxe form to get cuz a lot of the
songs on hot commodity are like fairly
old okay like the [__] that I was doing
like immediately after I dropped selfie
um but I got so much music so much music
and I think I want to like kick out the
rest that's like mixtape era you know
what I'm saying like this is me just I
want to rap rap you know well you know
what you could do is just put a new
project out and then it'll yeah but if I
do a new project it's going to be new
polished you know what I'm saying super
refined May versus like I'm coming up
I'm hungry I want to show you who I am
before you know what I'm saying I start
punching [__] in their face you know
not literally of course maybe
figuratively punch these [__] in
their face right figuratively and
sonically literally don't do it cuz then
you'll be in jail these [__] is
outside snitching bro you're right it's
rough I feel like every time I open my
phone I just see some people just be
snitching on themselves now like the
dude who got arrested for shooting Tupac
this dude's been doing interviews
admitting to this for like five years oh
really I don't know what's what you spok
about so this so this guy in vegas named
Kei D he got arrested uh by Las Vegas
Metro Police for his involvement in
Tupac's murder now the thing is is he's
been doing interviews for like he did
Vlad he's done a bunch of platforms I
don't want to just pin it on Vlad but
he's been talking about openly in like
describing the murder of Tupac and him
being there for like five years on
podcasts so it's it's like they came and
arrested him they came and they raided
his house they took bullets out of his
house and they put him in jail now he's
not convicted yet but this just happened
so it's like yeah what did you think was
going to [__] happen so he said like
like yeah I shot Tupac he was he said he
was in the passenger seat of the car
that killed
Tupac what his cousin is Orlando Brown
the dude who supposedly was the shooter
so it's like why would you admit that on
like they're like what like wait what
I'm confused I thought the P wait huh
it's crazy yeah I'm confused so they
arrested him for being a passenger yeah
because he was involved in the hit and
and the other dude's dead oh that was my
next question like why do they arrest
him he's dead so they proved that it was
the other guy yeah I mean I I
don't this guy admitted it I'm about to
go look up every I'm about to full down
a rabbit hole do it of that and then
I'mma text you like yo mhm I'mma find
out what's going on cuz that's
interesting well listen um hot commodity
go get the project you're on the road
all over the country with Flo Milly yes
yes so you can go support her live got
the merch popping
yes but it's not out yet you're you're
on tour you got to take the merch on
tour listen I made some last minute
decisions you got to sell the shirts to
the fans you know who you got to talk to
about that I rap all right I don't make
t-shirts well all right the merch is
coming soon y appreciate you pulling up
thank you for having me boom what's
going on man I want to shout out to our
family a hardan for presenting to you
another interview all right there's
another interview coming tomorrow and
the next day and the next day shout out
to harden though if you're in Las Vegas
man the number one dispensary in the
World there are family there are
brothers there are [__] dogs over
there man we love them they always are
taking care of us and they'll take care
of you if you go to harden in Vegas
let's say you're Landing in Vegas you're
going to go watch the Raiders you're
going to go watch a Vegas show whatever
get in that taxi tell them straight up
take me to harden when you get to harden
they will get you hooked up with the
craziest uh just variety and selection
of Premium cannabis on the planet and if
you tell them you heard about us on the
on on the bootle C show you say hey
Harden I heard about y'all on the
bootleg C podcast they're G to take care
of y'all all right so go follow them
Hardin Las Vegas on all social media and
check them out Hardin vegas.com what's
up Harden